inciso se encuentra todos los valores de
x en el intervalo menos 4 menor que x
menor que 3 en los cuales la gráfica de
que tenga un punto de inflexión da la
razón de tu respuesta bueno primero
vamos a recordar lo que es un punto de
inflexión un punto de inflexión es aquel
en donde la segunda derivada cambia de
signo es decir que si tomamos un punto
muy cercano al punto de inflexión la
segunda derivada va a cambiar de ser
positiva negativa o en dado caso de ser
negativa a ser positiva así que veamos
un ejemplo gráfico para ver qué es lo
que está sucediendo
miren voy a hacer una gráfica este de
aquí este de aquí va a ser mi función y
fíjense lo que es un punto de inflexión
vamos a analizar qué pasa con los
pendientes en mi recta tangente en cada
punto de mi función al principio las
pendientes son negativas hasta que
llegan al punto crítico en donde la
pendiente vale cero y después del punto
crítico en las pendientes se vuelven
positivas hasta aquí las pendientes
siempre han crecido hasta que llegan a
un punto en el cual la pendiente empieza
a decrecer
en un punto en el cual la pendiente
empieza a decrecer y a partir de ahí la
pendiente se vuelve de positiva a 0 y de
0 a negativa es ese punto donde las
pendientes cambian de crecer a decrecer
el punto de inflexión cuando la
pendiente cambia de crecer a decrecer
hay un punto de inflexión y de hecho
también al revés si la pendiente cambia
desde crecer a crecer también hay un
punto de inflexión
voy a dibujar esta función como si fuera
una función trigonométricas y dese
cuenta que aquí también hay otro punto
de inflexión porque la pendiente cambia
desde crecer a crecer sin embargo en mi
problema de x no está tan fácil de
visualizar en donde hay un punto
inflexión es decir dónde cambia de la
pendiente de que se ha de crecer o
viceversa entonces lo que vamos a hacer
es fijarnos en donde cambia de signo mi
segunda derivada así que vamos a poner
aquí hace de x que es igualdad 2x + la
integral de 0 a x df de tdt y vamos a
calcular su derivada
quien es la primera derivada de eje x
pues es la derivada de 2x que es 2 más
la derivada de la integral de 0 a x df
de tdt que por el teorema fundamental
del cálculo es simple y sencillamente fx
y así ya podemos calcular su segunda
derivada muy sencillo la derivada de 20
y la derivada de fx pues es efe prima de
x pero buscar en donde cambia la segunda
derivada de que designó va a ser
equivalente a buscar en donde cambia la
primera derivada de ft el signo lo que
quiero buscar donde cambian de signo y
bueno buscar donde cambio la primera
derivada de f de signo es buscar en
donde cambia de signo en la pendiente de
la recta tangente de f
es decir la pendiente de la recta
tangente de f
entonces vamos a la gráfica de f si nos
damos cuenta al principio la pendiente
es positiva porque es positiva positiva
positiva aquí sigue siendo positiva
vamos a colorearlo va a ser positiva
positiva positiva positiva positiva
aquí la pendiente sigue siendo positiva
aunque empieza a decrecer pero sigue
siendo positiva todo por el dispositivo
positivo positivo positivo y llega a un
punto en donde la pendiente cambia
drásticamente y a partir de ese punto la
pendiente ya es negativa
aquí la pendiente es negativa negativa
negativa en negativa negativa negativa
negativa entonces llegó a un punto en
donde la pendiente cambió de ser
positiva a ser negativa ahí está mi
cambio de signo sin embargo desde cuenta
que en este punto mi función
efe de x no es diferenciable y no es
diferenciable porque la función da un
salto de x 0 x igual a 3 de la nada sin
embargo no importa lo que nosotros
queríamos en un cambio de signo y aquí
tenemos una pendiente positiva y después
cambia a ser una pendiente negativa por
lo tanto hay un cambio de signo
este valor de x entonces ya tengo lo que
yo quería tenemos un cambio de signo en
la primera derivada de f que era igual a
un cambio de signo en la segunda
derivada de g y por lo tanto ya acabé
muy problema cuando x vale 0 la segunda
derivada deje de x tiene un cambio de
signo y por lo tanto la gráfica de eje x
tiene un punto de inflexión